prendre place les uns et les
autres j'entends
monsieur bien alors mes chers collègues
nous recevons à présent madame a berger
ministre des solidarité des familles sur
le projet de loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2024 j'indique que
cette audition fait l'objet une
captation vidéo retransmise en direct
sur le site du Sénat et disponible bien
entendu à la demande madame la ministre
je vais tout d'abord vous laisser
présenter les volets du PLFSS dont vous
avez la charge mais à cet égard comme je
l'ai déjà souligné le cours de
l'audition précédente devant le
directeur général de la CAF nous sommes
globalement assez frappés par le
l'absence d'une vér d'un véritable volet
famille au sein du PLFSS pour 2024 alors
même que les enjeux sont considérables
vous le savez bien le volet d'autonomie
est cert un peu pe plus fourni avec en
particulier la fusion des sections soins
indépendan des établissements je vous
indique tout de même que de nombreux
collègues lors d'édition d'audition
précédente se sont montré très inquiets
notamment du calibrage du fond d'urgence
donc nous aimerions avoir votre
sentiment autour de tout cela et puis
après votre intervention je donnerai
très rapidement la parole à nos
rapporteurs à la fois madame desessen
Monsieur H et notre rapporteur général
madame douano voilà madame la ministre
je vous laisse début cette
audition merci monsieur le Président
Madame la rapporteur générale Mesdames
et Messieurs les rapporteurs et mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs je suis très
heureuse de vous retrouver aujourd'hui
pour cette première audition
parlementaire pour ma part au Sénat donc
sur le projet de loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour 2024 je suis
d'autant plus que les sujets que nous
portons au ministère des solidarités et
des familles sont au cœur je crois des
besoins essentiels de nos concitoyens et
et de la nécessité du renforcement de
nos services publics parce qu'il s'agit
d'abord de nos familles de nos enfants
de la réponse à leurs besoins leur
épanouissement à leur développement il
est de notre responsabilité absolue de
lutter contre la baisse de la natalité
tendantielle depuis 10 ans et de
renforcer l'accompagnement de toutes les
familles en cohérence avec ma conception
universelle de la politique familiale la
politique familiale ne serait ce
transformer et se limiter à une
politique de redistribution ou de
correction des inégalités elle est d'AB
ord une politique qui appuie et qui
soutient toutes les familles dans le
respect de leurs choix il s'agit aussi
de nos aînés de nos parents et du
soutien à leur autonomie nous faisons
ainsi grandir vous l'avez dit monsieur
le Président la branche autonomie pour
relever le défi du vieillissement de
notre population soutenir toutes les
familles c'est bien les soutenir à tous
les âges de la vie il s'agit encore des
personnes en situation de handicap je
sais que vous y êtes très attentif ici
pour leur assurer une vie comme les
autres parmi les autres pour que le
droit commun applique à eux et à leurs
familles nous créons d'ici 2030 50000
solutions pour garantir l'inclusion et
la participation des personnes en
situation de handicap j'y reviendrai
évidemment le premier point donc les
familles elles sont dans toute leur
diversité le premier maillon de notre
société le creuset des apprentissages
fondamentaux de la vie collective de
l'expression des solidarités le retour
du terme famille dans la dénomination
même de mon ministère n'est pas le fruit
du hasard c'est un choix que j'ai fait
que nous avons fait et la réaffirmation
d'une priorité politique je souhaite
m'inscrire dans la lignée de ce choix
fort que notre pays a fait après la
guerre aider toutes les familles et s'en
donner les moyens cette ambition est
d'autant plus essentielle dans le
contexte de baisse continue de la
natalité que notre pays connaît depuis
10 ans avec une dégradation encore
accrue en 2023 nous devons tout faire
pour inverser la tendance c'est le sens
de l'action que le gouvernement mène
afin de renouer avec une politique
familiale universelle pour répondre aux
besoins de toutes les familles la
branche famille consacre comme vous le
savez plus de 50 milliards d'euros
chaque année à cet objectif avec une
hausse de 2 milliards d'euros pour
l'année 2024 en 2024 les moyens donc
consacrés à la politique familiale
augmenteront notamment pour mettre en
œuvre le chantier du service publque de
la petite enfance et je salue madame la
rapporteur qui a porté cette question
sur lequ dans le projet de loi plein
emploi qui vise à garantir à tout
parents l'accès à une solution d'accueil
de qualité et en toute sécurité pour
leur enfants en crè ou chez une
assistante maternelle proche de chez eux
et financièrement accessible nous le
savons la question de la garde d'enfants
elle est aujourd'hui le premier frein à
la réalisation des enfants au sein des
familles 6 milliards d'euros je pense
que le directeur général de la knaf a dû
y revenir sont consacrés à ce service
public jusqu'en 2027 c'est aussi la
question de la revalorisation des
professionnels de la petite enfance
parce que si nous voulons créer les 2000
solutions qui sont aujour 200000 pardon
solutions qui sont aujourd'hui
manquantes c'est ça signifie d'abord
accompagner les professionnels soutenir
toutes les familles c'est aussi soutenir
les mares seuls le PLFSS intègre vous le
savez à la fois des aides monétaires qui
sont revalorisées à hauteur de 4,6 %
pour le mois d'avril comme l'aide de
soutien aux familles c'està-dire la
pension alimentaire minimale dont nous
avons augmenté de 50 % le montant
l'année dernière au total la trajectoire
de la branche famille inscrite dans ce
texte atteindra 63 milliards de dépenses
en 2000 27 20 % de plus qu'en 2022 avec
notamment l'entrée en vigueur d'une
double réforme de l'aide individuelle à
la garde d'enfant vous savez le
complément du libre choix du mode de
garde CMG il sera étendu pour toutes les
familles monoparentales jusqu'aux 11 ans
révolus de l'enfant il sera modifié
encore en 2025 pour qu'enfin le reste à
charge soit le même pour toutes les
familles qu'elles choisissent de faire
garder leurs enfants en crèche ou auprès
d'une assistante maternelle je m'assure
évidemment que ces moyens soient
dépensés effectivement et efficacement
au pour garantir la qualité de la prise
en charge et la sécurité de nos enfants
je prendrai qu'un seul exemple je l'ai
dit on aura une revalorisation de 200
millions d'euros chaque année au
bénéfice des professionnels de la petite
enfance mais pas 1 € pas 1 € nira à des
structures qui n'améliorerait pas les
conditions de travail des professionnels
c'est tout le travail que nous faisons
aujourd'hui dans le cadre des
conventions collectives enfin quand on
parle natalité il y a un chiffre qu'on
regarde peu et qui est pourtant très
parlant c'est notamment celui que porte
l'UNAF vous le savez dans ces études qui
fait qu'aujourd'hui on a un écart
grandissant entre le désir d'enfant et
le nombre d'enfants mis au monde dans
chaque famille le désir d'enfant il est
constant il est à peu près à 2,4 enfants
par femme quand les couples aujourd'hui
ont plutôt 1,8 enfants en moyenne ma
responsabilité elle est bien là réduire
le plus possible cet écart pour
permettre au couple qui le souhaite
d'avoir effectivement des enfants le
service public de la petite enfance et
là encore une première réponse mais nous
devons aller plus loin je pense
notamment à certains tabou que nous
devons lever par exemple sur la question
de l'infertilité travaux que nous menons
évidemment en lien avec le ministre de
la santé et de la prévention en laissant
aussi plus de liberté de choix aux
familles c'est la réforme que je
souhaite voir aboutir du congé parental
j'ai lancé la concertation avec les
organisations syndicales et patronnales
dès la semaine dernière en lien avec les
annonces de la première ministre faite
lors de la conférence sociale du 16
octobre dernier notre objectif il est
clair évoluer vers une période
d'interruption choisi mieux indemnisé
mieux partagé entre les parents les
solidarités et la famille c'est aussi
tout au long de la vie c'est pourquoi
plus que jamais la question de
l'autonomie elle doit nous
préoccuper nous préoccuper parce que
nous faisons face et nous ferons face à
un défi démographique si ce n'est à un
choc démographique dans les années à
venir deux chiffres qui sont très
éclairant je trouve en 2030 un Français
sur 3 aura plus de 60 ans et pour la la
première fois dans l'histoire de notre
pays les plus de 65 ans seront plus
nombreux que les moins de 15 ans en
cohérence avec cette engagement
l'objectif global de dépenses qui
finance donc nos établissements et pour
personnes âgées et pour personnes en
situation de handicap augmente de 4 %
c'est-à-dire au-delà des 2,5 %
d'inflation anticipée cette hausse des
moyens elle traduit nos engagements
envers les familles mais aussi envers
les professionnels du secteur ces
engagements je vaux vous en rappeler
quelques-uns qui me sem
important d'abord répondre à la demande
faite par les personnes directement
concernées et d'abord leur première
demande c'est le fait de pouvoir
vieillir chez elle à domicile c'est la
question du virage domiciliaire et nous
mettrons en œuvre dès janvier 2024 ma
prime adable qui est une nouvelle aide
financière qui doit permettre
l'adaptation des logements et la
prévention aussi de la perte d'autonomie
je pense par exemple à la question des
chutes qui est un sujet qui
malheureusement parfois fait un peu
sourire mais qui est en fait absolument
déterminant sur la capacité d'autonomie
des personnes les moyens ils sont
également mis sur la poursuite du
développement des nouveaux centres de
ressources territoriaux pour
décloisonner là encore les interventions
près des personnes âgées à domicile et
simplifier leur démarche ces centres de
ressources ils vont pouvoir s'inscrire
dans la dynamique du service public
départemental de l'autonomie pour enfin
mettre un terme parcours du combattant
que nous connaissons tous que sur
lesquels les Français nous alertent sur
cette espèce d'érance et jeis le dire de
maltraitance parfois administrative et
institutionnelle que nous imposons aux
familles c'est un projet d'humanisation
et de simplification de nos services
publics l'appel à manifestation
d'intérêt est parti dè septembre auprès
de l'ensemble des conseils
départementaux pour sélectionner des
premiers territoires pilotes je vous
invite évidemment mesieurs les sénateurs
à inciter vos départements à être
candidat et à pouvoir se manifester donc
leur intérêt comme le nom l'indique on a
évidemment d'autres réformes
structurelles je pense notamment à la
question des aides à domicile
l'instauration vous le savez d'un tarif
plancher 22 € en 202 augmenté à 23 € en
2023 et indexé indirectement sur
l'inflation à partir de l'an prochain la
dotation complémentaire ce qu'on a
appelé le bonus qualité les 3 €
supplémentaires la création de 25000
nouvelles places en de SIAT d'ici 2030
et les 2 heures supplémentaires dédié à
l'accompagnement et surtout à la lutte
contre l'isolement social en particulier
pour les bénéficiaires de la pas là
encore à partir du 1er janvier nous
irons plus loin puisque nous vous savez
qu'à l'Assemblée nationale nous
reprendrons la semaine du 20 novembre
l'examen de la proposition de loi bien
vieillir évidemment j'espère ensuite
dans les meilleurs délais au Sénat
puisqu'on a des éléments très concrets
de réponse sur la carte professionnelle
pour les aides à domicile sur le fond de
soutien à la mobilité qui doit pouvoir
leur être accordé la lutte contre les
maltraitances aussi parce que je
souhaite aussi que nous proposions un
véritable parcours résidentiel adapt aux
besoins et aux envies de nos concitoyens
nous devons je crois continuer si ce
n'est vraiment enfin commencer à
développer sur l'ensemble de notre
territoire des structures d'habitat
intermédiaire en clair il y a
l'investissement sur le virage
domiciliaire il y a des épades sans
doute de plus en plus médicalisé mais il
y a tout le parcours qui doit pouvoir
exister entre le domicile et l'Pad avec
notamment la question de l'habitat
inclusif des résidences autonomie des
résidences seniores et là encore j'ai
réuni le comité des financeurs c'est qui
réunissent certains présidents de
département choisis par l'ADF et euh la
CNSA de manière à ce qu'on puisse
ensemble travailler à une vraie réforme
des fonds de concours et je crois
notamment que la CNSA doit pouvoir être
un outil de pilotage très efficace des
politiques publiques de manière à
accélérer sur ces enjeux de parcours
résidentiel et ces parcours résidentiels
ils sont évidemment très liés à l'offre
d'accompagnement des personnes âgées en
établissement d'où l'enjeu du
recrutement face à la pénurie de
professionnel et la trajectoire vous le
savez de 50000 postes supplémentaires en
éepad d'ici 2000 30 3000 postes ont été
ouverts l'an dernier ce sera 6000 cette
année ça veut dire qu'on arrive à tenir
cette trajectoire extrêmement exigeante
qu'aorté le président de la République
c'est aussi un enjeu d'attractivité
c'est pas juste de budgetter des postes
mais il faut garantir surtout qu'on est
ensuite des candidats pour les pourvoirs
c'est la raison pour laquelle j'ai
obtenu que les infirmiers et de
soignants en épat de public bénéficient
de la même mesure de revalorisation pour
le travail de nuit et les jours fériers
que leurs collègues des établissements
public sanitaire et pareil j'ai pu
annoncer que cette extension extension
pardon concernerait également le secteur
privé non lucratif je crois que c'est
extrêmement important il y a pas le
sanitaire d'un côté le médico-social de
l'autre les deux doivent travailler de
concerts parce qu'ils sont concernés par
les mêmes difficultés et qu'encore une
fois il y a pas de hiérarchie évidemment
à avoir entre les professionnels qui
travaillent et qui travaille avec
énormément d'engagement enfin vous
l'avez relevé en m'interpellant sur la
question du fond d'urgence monsieur
monsieur le Président je n'ignore
évidemment rien des difficultés
financières d'un grand nombre de nos
épales je me rendrai dans les Côtes
d'Armor par exemple cette semaine
interpellé par le président du
département sur ce sujet-là oui nous
avons débloqué un fond d'urgence de 100
millions d'euros avec la première
ministre dès cette été l'objectif c'est
quoi c'est surtout d'installer des
commissions départementales ce qui
n'existait pas de mettre autour de la
table enfin les créanciers et les
financeurs j'ai d'ailleurs redonné
directement instruction à l'ensemble des
ARS que les Parlement soit
systématiquement tenu informé de ces
réunions et de leur suivi de manière à
ce que vous ayez accès aux informations
donc si jamais il y avait des loup
monsieur le Président n'hésitez pas à
m'interpeller directement que je repasse
les messages il une culture aussi qu'il
faut changer au sein parfois de nos
administrations déconcentrées mais ces
commissions départementales au-delà
uniquement de pouvoir soutenir
financièrement les éepad ou les services
d'aide à domicile les plus en difficulté
doivent pouvoir nous permettre d'établir
une cartographie pour ça savoir quelles
sont les difficultés conjoncturelles et
quelles sont les difficultés
structurelles des 7500 éepad que nous
avons dans notre pays et puis on doit
avoir des réformes plus structurelles le
PLFSS apporte une première réponse
structurelle vous le savez avec la
possibilité pour les départements qu'il
souhaitent j'insiste bien uniquement
pour les départements qu'il souhaitent
d'avoir une reprise de la section soins
avec la fusion entre les sections soins
et dépendance directement je crois que
ça c'est une mesure qui
importante structurelle en terme de
financement évidemment de nos
établissements et là encore ce sera au
libre choix des départements puisque une
fois le PLFSS adopté on choisira des
départements pilotes qui donc auront
manifesté leur intérêt et je vous le
disais la réforme des fonds de concours
qui doit pour moi garantir enfin une
vraie lisibilité à la politique publique
que nous menons en matière d'autonomie
je l'ai dit au président de département
au président de laadf je le redis
évidemment devant vous qui quelque part
est représenté aussi rien ne se décidera
sans ou contre les départements moi le
sujet n'est absolument pas une
quelconque recentralisation des
compétences je crois à l'échelon
départemental je crois à la nécessité
d'avoir des politiques décentralisées au
plus près de nos concitoyens mais je
crois évidemment je pense comme vous à
la nécessité de l'équité territoriale
pour qu'on nit pas des situations de
certains de nos concitoyens nous
alertent en nous disant qu'ils n'ont pas
le même niveau de prise en charge en
fonction du département dans lequel ils
sont ce qui crée évidemment beaucoup de
complexité de doutes sur nos politiques
publiques à nous de mieux les
accompagner de mieux les soutenir et je
souhaite avec la réforme des fonds de
concours qu'on puisse soutenir plus et
mieux les départements c'est clairement
l'objectif que j'ai assigné à la CNSA en
lien donc avec le comité des financeurs
et donc les présidents des départements
enfin dernier point je sais que vous
êtes très attentif personnellement
monsieur le Président la question du
handicap et de la mise en œuvre des
promesses et des engagements qui ont été
ceux du président de la République dans
le cadre évid éamment de la Conférence
nationale du handicap c'est notamment la
question des 50000 nouvelles solutions
pour les personnes en situation de
handicap volontairement met solution au
pluriel parce que je crois que parfois
trop longtemps on a considéré qu'il
fallait un bloc d'uni solution non en
vérité les personnes en situation de
handicap leur famille elles attendent
une multiplicité de solutions qui
répondent réellement à leurs
préoccupations à leurs besoins que ce
soit le droit à la scolarité y compris
en milieu et en institut médico éducatif
je ne veux plus on est des enfants qui
nous qui a droit à une demi matinée de
cours par semaine parce que ça veut dire
en vérité pas de cours du tout et une
prise en charge adapté aussi de nos
enfants qui sont à l'aide sociale à
l'enfance o on nous dit qu'aujourd'hui
20 % d'entre eux en vérité sont en
situation de handicap ça veut dire
qu'ils ne sont pas bien pris en charge
aujourd'hui et donc qu'on est
collectivement défaillant à leur égard
et une priorité que j'ai fixé dans le
cadre de ces 50000 nouvelles solutions
ce sont vous le savez ces 10000 adultes
qui qui sont encore aujourd'hui dans des
établissements pour mineurs les 10000
amendements Creton je veux que les 50000
nouvelles solutions soient en priorité
créé pour les adultes en situation de
handicap qu'on voit moins dont on parle
moins et qui permettrait d'avoir une
meilleure prise en charge correspondant
à leurs besoins à leur dignité mais
aussi de libérer évidemment les places
qui sont aujourd'hui occupées alors
qu'elle devrait être dévolu à des
enfants moi je souhaite qu'on puisse en
vérité mettre un terme définitif à ces
amendements cretons mais on ne le fera
qu'évidemment si on a des solutions à
mettre en face de chacune des personnes
directement concernées autre mesure clé
pour 2025 c'est la question d'un
véritable service de repérage
d'orientation des situations de handicap
chez les enfants de 0 à 6 ans c'est une
question évidemment d'accompagnement et
de soutien aux familles c'est une
question aussi faire en sorte d'éviter
de lutter contre les pertes de chance
parce que plus on détecte précocément
mieux on peut accompagner mieux on peut
prendre en charge et enfin faciliter la
vie des personnes en situation de
handicap c'est aussi la question du
reste à charge de ces familles dont on
sait qu'il est particulièrement élevé
c'était une mesure très symbolique mais
très attendue sur la prise en charge
vous le savez à 100 % des fauteuil
roulant en moyenne on a aujourd'hui
60000 de nos compatriotes qui déboursent
plus de 5000 € pour avoir un fauteuil
adapté on a pris l'engagement et ça a
été même corrigé à l'Assemblée nationale
pour qu'il y ait aucune ambiguïé sur
l'intention du gouvernement que soit
bien tous les fauteuils qui soi manuel
qu'il soit électrique avec toutes les
adaptation les spécificités en fonction
des handicaps qui seront pris en charge
donc même des fauteuils qui peuvent être
à 20000 à 30000 € tout sera pris en
charge par l'État c'est une petite
révolution et c'est surtout un vrai
changement très concret dans la vie des
familles bref je veux plus voir des
cagnottes sur Internet juste pour avoir
le droit d'avoir un fauteuil les progrès
que j'ai évoqué pour accompagner et les
personnes âgées et les personnes en
situation de handicap elles sont
possibles aussi grâce à ce que vous et
nous avons voté c'est-à-dire la création
de cette 5e branche avec vous le savez
ces 0,15 points de CSG qui sont dévolu
c'est 2,6 milliards d'euros qui viennent
abonder les ressources de la 5e branche
nous consommons la moitié de ce surplu
dès 2024 et la trajectoire de dépenses
que nous avons envisagé le consomme
presque intégralement d'ici 2027 en
clair il y a pas de cagnotte qui soit
faite sur cette 5e branche il y a la
volonté de tracer une trajectoire et de
garantir évidemment le financement de
cette trajectoire enfin le texte qui est
pour l'instant présenté il reprend à
l'Assemblée nationale déjà des évolution
euh que je tiens à vous indiquer des
avis favorables que le gouvernement a
apporté sur un certain nombre
d'amendements qui sont portés à
l'Assemblée nationale euh la question
des aidents familiaux avec Fadila katabi
donc qui est la ministre déléguée au
personnes personnes handicapées nous
avons présenté une stratégie qui
garantit notamment les 15 jours de répi
qui garantit que d'ici la fin du qu
quinquena nous ayons 40000 solutions de
répi pour les aidents en particulier les
aidents familiaux et bien nous pouvons
avoir des amendements là qui viennent
mieux soutenir et renforcer ces points
deux éléments l'expérimentation du
dispositif de relayage le relayage vous
le savez directement au domicile des
personnes qui je crois une très belle
expérimentation il prenaent fin si on ne
venait pas
modifier les choses à la fin de l'année
l'idée c'est de le prolonger en 2024
j'espère avant une généralisation parce
que je crois qu'on aura un bilan
suffisamment solide pour garantir une
généralisation c'est la question aussi
du cumul de l'allocation journalière du
prochédent pour chaque personne aidé
parce qu'on peut être aidant plusieurs
fois dans sa vie et en même temps au
bénéfice de plusieurs personnes et puis
enfin dans le cadre de la politique
aussi familiale qu'on veut la plus
universelle possible c'est corriger des
effets de bord c'est notamment le
faciliter par exemple
la prise du congé paternité pour les
pères agriculteurs qui dé facto sont une
dépopulation qui était les moins
concerné par la possibilité de l'avoir
parce qu'il n'av pas la possibité de se
faire remplacer tout simplement dans
leurs exploitation mais je ne doute pas
que le Sénat aura sans doute des
volontés de faire encore évoluer ce
PLFSS et je suis évidemment à votre
disposition monsieur le Président Madame
la rapporteur générale mesames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs et sénateurs
merci madame la ministre pour vos propos
finalement c'est un un vrai discours de
politique générale qui montre vos
ambitions concernant les volets et donc
un grand merci en tous les cas de de
poser cet acte en début d'audition alors
nous allons maintenant nous recentrer
parulement sur la partie du du pfss et
donc je va commencer par donner la
parole àabeth douanau notre rapporteur
général merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais vous remercier Madame la
Ministre parce que vous montrez à
travers vos propos et la façon dont vous
les tenez beaucoup d'énergie et beaucoup
de volonté c'est vrai que ça ressemble
peu finalement à une traduction de ce
PLFSS 2024 qui est un petit peu faible
sur les propositions il y a un décalage
très honnêtement mais on sent votre
volonté en tout cas de nous faire un
certain nombre de
propositions je voudrais m'attarder sur
un point la loi de du 20 août 2020 du 7
août 2020 indiquait donc que le PLFSS
202 24 rentrerait 0,15 points
de CSG donc qui était à la auparavant à
la CNSA c'est environ 2,6 milliards
d'euros or l'article 10 de ce PLFSS
2024 indique une neutralité de
l'augmentation de la compensation au
département sur la PA et sur la
PCH ça se situerait environ à 250
millions d'euros je me dis que c'est
sans doute pas un bon signal à envoyer
alors que les départements font face à
des augmentations
sur le plan de de la perte d'autonomie
sur le vieillissement de la population
qu'est-ce qui a guidé ce choix et et
comment vous le justifiez en fait
comment vous justifiez cette disposition
le deuxième point est plutôt une
remarque général sur le sentiment qu'on
n concitoyens par rapport au
vieillissement de la population sur ce
fond d'urgence en particulier alors
certes 100 million d'euros c'est une
somme moi je pense qu'il faut aussi que
les département euh mettent la main euh
aussi quand ils le peuvent quand ils le
peuvent certains le peuvent et donc
c'est là où il faut essayer de de
comment de de négocier hein mais en tout
cas comment donner le sentiment
finalement que
toutes les structures qui en ont besoin
pourront en bénéficier parce que c'est
vrai que quand on regarde les réseaux
sociaux quand on entend parler les uns
et les autres on a le sentiment que
c'est le premier premier qui décroche
cette aide qui qui va l'obtenir et on
arrivera très vite à à avoir usé des 100
millions ou peut-être plus si les
département accorde quelques financement
moi j'ai j'ai peur qu'on tombe comme sur
le séure c'est-à-dire sur un sentiment
d'inéquité c'estàdire le sentiment de
frustration c'estàdire que les premiers
servic seront servis mais ceux d'après
on ne sait pas après pour la CNSA il y a
un certain nombre de de moyens qui sont
donnés à la CNSA moi je voudrais que
vous soyez très attentive madame la
ministre à la façon dont ils sont
distribués parce que finalement c'est
les plus habiles qui encore une fois
vont décrocher des financements
importants et je le vois déjà sur
certains territoires c'est-à-dire qu'en
fait ils vont pendant plusieurs années
bénéficier de moyens alors que d'autres
qui ont peut-être moins de moyens en
terme d'ingénierie ou de connaissance
des possibilités ne vont pas obtenir et
moi je veux que vous soyez très très
attentive vraiment à cet esprit d'équité
senti parce que sinon c'est beaucoup de
frustration et on va retomber dans les
oubliés comme on a eu les oubliés du
Ségur merci merci beaucoup je donne la
parole
Olivier merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre merci pour vos vos
propos alors déjà dans la presse
d'ailleurs on avait vu combien la
question de la famille la question de la
natalité était au cœur de de vos
préoccupations mais on va vous donner le
préjugé favorable parce que vous n'êtes
pas ministre depuis très longtemps mais
forcé de reconnaître que il y a quand
même un décalage entre l'ambition que
que vous affichez et puis la réalité de
ce PLFSS et moi je suis un peu comme le
docteur houseous voyez-vous ce ne sont
pas les mots qui comptent mais ce sont
les actes hein ça dans la série souvent
ça ça ça ça revient donc quelques
questions parce que quand même il me
semble que du point de vue du
PLFSS il faut quand même un certain
nombre de de de cap et de de de deux
priorités d'abord une première la
politique familiale universelle qui a
été le concept que vous avez décliné
est-ce que ça veut dire le retour à
l'universalité des allocations
familiales donc à la situation
concrètement hein à la situation qui
était celle d'avant la la la décision du
gouvernement d'Emmanuel Vals voilà
est-ce que c'est ça que ça veut dire la
la politique familiale universelle ou
alors qu'est-ce que ça veut dire si
c'est pas ça ensuite euh sur la question
du congé parental j'y reviendrai sur une
question plus précise mais sur le le
est-ce que vous avez un un un un
calendrier sur les l'évolution on a eu
un un rapport avec ma collègue Anil
werou est-ce que vous avez une question
par rapport à à ce ce ce question de ce
ce ce concept du de l'évolution du congé
parental est-ce qu'il y a un calendrier
sur le complément mode de garde euh
effectivement il y a aussi des choses
qui sont prévu n pas notamment par
rapport au au complément mode de regarde
direct sur la question des des
ressources
humaines et du du du manque de personnel
dans les crèches comment allez-vous
faire pour faire en sorte de de rendre
attractif ces métiers et enfin sur le le
régime d'autorisation et sur les
contrôles nécessairein vous avez aussi
évoqué cette cette question est-ce que
ça veut dire concrètement des moyens
supplémentaires pour les PMI lesquels
parce que pour que ces régimes
d'autorisation soient effectués
correctement il faut évidemment que les
PMI en aent les moyens et idem pour les
contrôles et qu'est-ce que vous
envisagez concrètement à la fois dans ce
PLFSS et puis dans le calendrier et
enfin en étant factuel voilà le le le
seul positif de la branche famille c'est
réduit de 2 milliards d'euros en 2023 en
raison d'un transfert de charge lesi
hein j'y reviens pas on en a a parlé
longuement l'année dernière mais euh
l'excédent en 2024 ne sera que de 800
millions d'euros et est-ce que vous ne
traignez pas compte tenu de toutes les
ambitions que vous affichez et
finalement les partage qui est quand
même un fort décalage entre les
ambitions que vous afficher et la
réalité de de de de de de des
financements dont dispose la branche
famille compte tenu de ces transferts de
charges je vous remercie merci beaucoup
et Chantal des scèes maintenant merci
monsieur le Président merci madame la
ministre on sent dans vos propos un
véritable engagement euh je voudrais que
vous nous apportiez quelques précisions
en particulier sur la fusion des
sections soins et autonomie puisque
c'est une option prise par les
départements irréversible ne
craignez-vous pas que ça crée un régime
à deux vitesses puisqu'on aura les
départements qui auront opté pour la
fusion et puis ceux qui seront encore en
en attente éventuellement de le faire
pourquoi ne pas parler d'une
expérimentation qu'on évalue au bout de
2 3 ans avant de généraliser et pour les
départements qui souhaiteraient mettre
en place la fusion dès 2025 de quels
éléments éléments
financiers
disposent-il je voudrais aussi vous
parler de la situation des services à
domicile parce que effectivement vous
souhaitez
un virage
domiciliaire sauf que il est abordé très
timidement qu'il y a très peu de moyens
vous parlez de 25000 places où en est-on
de cet objectif et quelles sont vos
propositions en matière de recrutement
donc pour les services à domicile mais
aussi dans les
épad parce que bon vous le savez la la
profession n'est pas forcément très
attractive il y a un certain nombre de
contraintes et cetera et donc on peut on
peut avoir avir des ambitions mais quels
moyens on met à leur
service et puis je voudrais terminer
enfin j'auris plein d'autres questions
mais on aura sûrement l'occasion d'en
échanger puis mes collègues
compléteront sur l'article
38 qui vise à mettre en place un service
de diagnosticque précoce et de prise en
charge précoce euh est-ce que vous
pouvez me dire ce que ça a pteant plus
par rapport à ce qui existe déjà on a
déjà l'époque on a déjà les camps on a
déjà des structures pour les TND et
cetera quelle est l'ambition de cet
article 38 est-ce que voilà je vais le
dire comme je le pense est-ce que c'est
un petit peu un affichage qu'est-ce
qu'il y a derrière et quel service ça va
apporter en plus aux enfants qui sont en
situation de de handicap et qui aurait
besoin d'être diagnostiqué précocement
en sachant quand même qu'il y a un
certain nombre de visites obligatoires
jusqu'aux 2 ans de l'enfant et que donc
tous les services que ce soit les les
médecins libéraux les pédiatres les PMI
et cetera euh en les crèches l'école
après à partir de 3 ans il y a déjà tout
tout un tas de de de de de dispositifs
qui existent pour repérer ses enfants
donc quelle est l'ambition de cette que
38 Merci Merci beaucoup madame desen je
vous laisse Madame le Ministre
répondre je vais essayer peut-être pour
que soit plus cohérent de répondre non
pas forcément dans l'ordre si ça vous
convient mais répondre par sujet par par
thématique d'abord sur la question de de
la branche autonomie et en général de
l'accompagnement de la perte d'autonomie
dans notre pays sur la branche autonomie
oui on a donc les 015 points de CSG ça
fait bien en effet 2,6 milliards on en
consomme la moitié permettant d'éviter
déjà à la branche de tomber en déficit
dès 2024 parce que sinon il y avait un
risque de déficit de la branche
autonomie d'1,3 milliards dès 2024 je
crois que c'est ça le premier élément à
avoir en tête et garantissant aussi que
l'ensemble des engagements que j'ai pris
au nom du Gouvernement devant vous soit
tenu pour 2027 c'està-dire qu'on
garantit encore une fois une trajectoire
concrètement ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'on garantit les la montée en
charge des 5 50000 nouveaux personnel
soignants je disais 3000 en 2023 6000 en
2024 pour arriver au 50000 en 2030 on
garantit l'intégral l'intégralité du
financement du tarif plancher pour les
aides à domicile qui est un enjeu majeur
évidemment sur la revalorisation de ces
métiers et là encore on a fait monter en
puissance on garantit aussi le
financement à 100 % de la dotation
qualité donc vous savez ce bonus qualité
de 3 € supplémentairire et on garantit
les 50000 nouvelles solutions puisque
dans la branche autonomie peut-être que
c'est une dénomination qui n'est qui ne
permet pas de rendre compte de
l'intégralité du champ mais c'est aussi
la question évidemment du handicap et
les 50000 nouvelles solutions donc c'est
tout ça qui est financé après vient la
question de comment on coordonne cette
action en lien avec les compétences dont
vous savez bien qu'elles sont partagées
avec les départements et pour moi le bon
outil de pilotage c'est la CNSA qui en
vérité ne s'est pas vu assigner je crois
un rôle réel de pilotage de politique
publique on l'a vu passé expression un
peu comme un porte-monnaie dans lequel
les uns et les autres allaient piocher
pour réaliser des actions l'enjeu c'est
de mettre de la cohérence en fait donc
quelle est la politique publique que
l'on veut avoir dans notre pays et en
fonction des besoins des départements en
fonction de l'évolution démographique
des départements en fonction de la
population vieillissante de ces
départements en fonction aussi des
maladies neurodégénératifes par exemple
qui risque de concerner jusqu'à 1,2
million de personnes et cetera donc moi
ce que j'ai demandé à la CNSA c'est que
en lien avec le comité des financeurs
qui est donc tout à fait partagé entre
les présidents des départements 14 qui
ont été désignés par laadf ça n'est pas
nous qui avons choisi ces représentants
vous le savez et la CNSA et à la demande
du président de laadf c'est maintenant
le Ministre en charge en l'espè moi-même
qui préside ces réunions de comité de
financeur ce que j'ai demandé à la CNSA
c'est d'avoir des
simulations département par département
de cette évolution démographique pour
mieux prendre conscience connaissance de
ce qui va se produire et donc des
besoins existants des départements et ça
ça se coordonne bien avec justement les
commissions départementales qu'on a
installé et qui sont installés dans tous
les départements depuis fin septembre
aujourd'hui si vous me posiez la
question de dire c'est quoi la situation
des epads mais je ne sais pas vous dire
la situation de chacun des éepads je
sais vous dire que on a évidemment des
alertes qu'on a des déficits qui
existent dans beaucoup trop de nos EPAD
mais est-ce que ça veut dire que ce sont
des déficit conjoncturel parce qu'ils
font face à la revalorisation des
personnels à l'augmentation de les prix
de l'énergie malgré le bouclier
tarifaire à l'augmentation des prix de
l'alimentation et cetera où est-ce que
ce sont des difficultés structurelles
parce que ici tel ou tel épan ne
correspond plus aux besoins de la
population à l'évolution de cette
population à l'évolution de sa prise en
charge c'est ça qu'on doit savoir et
donc c'est fort de ces simulations sur
l'évolution démographique fort de cette
cartographie qu'on doit pouvoir faire
établissement par établissement qu'on
doit pouvoir avoir un vrai pilote age
ensuite avec la CNSA de comment on
accompagne et on soutient mieux les
départements moi je pense que on a les
moyens grâce à la branche autonomie de
mieux prendre en charge les dépenses des
départements moi c'est ça que je leur ai
proposé que je leur ai mis sur la table
dans le comité des financeurs c'est que
dès 2024 il y a une première évolution
parce que je sais qu'il y a une
situation qui est tendue du fait du
marché immobilier notamment dans les
différents départements la situation est
tendue pour beaucoup de nos conseils
départementaux donc moi je suis prête à
ce qu'on ait une première évolution en
clair une première enveloppe budgétaire
supplémentaire des 2024 mais qu'on ait
une vraie réforme systémique des fonds
de concours mon objectif c'est on arrête
les 12 fonds de concours on arrête de se
dire qu'à chaque nouvelle politique
publique on empile un nouveau fond de
concours parce qu'en clair c'est ça qui
s'est passé chaque nouveau ministre
chaque nouvelle politique avait un
nouveau fond de concours c'est pas ce
que je veux je veux qu'on clarifie je
veux qu'on change l'organisation des
critères parce que ça permettra de
piloter mieux et d'accompagner mieux les
départements et encore une fois dans une
logique partenariale avec les
départements on fera pas sans eux ils ne
feront pas sans nous donc je pense
qu'ils en sont tous conscients et pour
répondre à ce que vous disiez madame la
rapporteur générale je pense aussi qu'il
faut accepter l'idée qu'on accompagne
aussi mieux les départements soit qui en
ont le plus besoin soit qui sont les
plus engagés moi il y a beaucoup de
présidents de conseil départementaux qui
me disent attendez nous on a fait les
efforts on avait mis en place en fait un
tarif plancher bah avant que l'État le
fasse on avait déjà revalorisé les
rémunérations on a augmenté le tarif
journalier mais finalement on a va
peut-être pas aider les meilleurs élèves
pour le dire un peu clairement et ben je
crois qu'il faut évidemment aider tous
pour garantir une prise en charge de nos
concitoyens parce qu'il est pas question
de laisser tomber des établissements et
donc de laisser tomber des bénéficiaires
et des résidents mais c'est quand même
légitime de se dire qu'à un moment on va
pouvoir soutenir d'autant plus ceux qui
s'engagent ce qui n'a pas été totalement
l'état d'esprit ces dernières années et
que je souhaite un peu revoir dans cet
esprit d'équité pour reprendre vos
propos madame la rapporteur générale et
sur la question de la répartition des
100 millions d'euros alors manière très
claire on a essayé d'avoir des clés de
répartition un peu objective en fonction
à la fois du nombre population
département par département et aussi de
la proportion des plus de 65 ans dans
ces départements qui justifi en général
qu'on ait une un risque de perte
d'autonomie et donc des besoins
supplémentaires donc ça c'est le travail
que les ARS ont fait pour garantir qu'on
ait une répartition équitable est-ce que
ça veut pas veut dire qu'on ira pas
au-delà des 100 millions d'euros la
réponse est NON et on est en train de le
faire en fonction des départements de
leurs besoins et de leurs engagements
notamment avec ce qu'on appelle les
crédits non reconductibles des ARS de
manière à évaluer département par
département les besoins les nécessités
les engagements aussi qui sont pris par
les départements et c'est pour ça que
j'ai pu annoncer dans certains
départements des engagements
supplémentaires mais des engagements
supplémentaires j'allais dire sont pas
faits la tête du client au hasard mais
qui sont faits selon des critères
objectivable dans chacun des
départements enfin sur la question de la
fusion des sections soins et dépendance
l'idée n'est pas de le rendre
irréversible moi j'assume totalement
l'idée d'une expérimentation appelez ça
des départements pilotes et encore une
fois certains voulaienter plus loin en
disant généraliser tout de suite non
c'est contraire à l'idée qu'on se fait
et j'imagine que vous faites d'autant
plus ici de la décentralisation et donc
de la différenciation territoriale qu'on
peut avoir il faut à un moment on a des
départ artement qui ne sont pas dans les
mêmes situations budgétaires dans les
mêmes situations démographiques et donc
qui n'ont pas les mêmes nécessités il y
a ceux qui vont très vite vouloir
s'engager parce qu'il voient bien que
c'est leur intérêt et qu'en terme de
finances publiqu ils ne tiendront pas
sinon et donc c'est cela qu'on va s'ans
doute prioritairement aussi choisir pour
garantir encore une fois l'équité
territoriale le soutien qu'on doit aux
personnes qui sont directement
accompagnées mais l'idée n'est ni de se
dire que par principe ça doit augurer
d'une
généralisation moi je ne crois pas ça
mais et qu'on a une vraie
expérimentation et en tout cas moi
j'assume de dire qu'on ne généralise pas
avant la fin d'une expérimentation sinon
ça veut dire qu'il y a pas
d'expérimentation si on expériment c'est
justement pour en recueillir les fruits
pour objectiver et pour évaluer sinon
dans ces cas-là bon c'est contraire je
trouve à l'essence même de ce que doit
être je crois une une expérimentation en
tout cas moi je je l'assume très
clairement sur ces sujets là deuxième
point sur la la question de la politique
familiale et je vous remercie d'avoir
noté mon mon engagement et mon énergie
je vais faire en sorte Ste que c'est dur
et de vous en convaincre surtout dans
les actes qu'on va pouvoir mettre en
place déjà sur tous les droits nouveaux
con crée c'est l'état d'esprit qui me
guide que ce soit sur la réforme du
complément mode de garde par exemple
aujourd'hui vous n'aviez pas la même
prise en charge si vous mettiez votre
enfant auprès d'une assistante
maternelle ou si vous mettiez votre
enfant dans une microocèche c'est pas
normal parce qu'à la fin en vérité
est-ce que les parents font vraiment un
choix pas toujours les parents ils font
surtout certains d'entre vous le sont
ici bah avec les possibilités de garde
qu'ils ont dans leur
environnement et ils ne n'ont pas
forcément les capacités d'arbitrage pour
dire je préféra une assistante
maternelle je préfére un accueil
collectif donc on va pas en plus les
pénaliser en disant bah au regard du
choix que vous avez fait vous azêre plus
ou moins soutenu non donc maintenant on
arrête c'est le même reste à charge pour
l'ensemble des parents modulo évidemment
un niveau de revenu la composition
familiale et cetera mais je crois que
déjà ça ça redit quand même de ce que
doit être une politique universelle j'ai
réfléchi vous l'avez dit sur la question
du congé parental j'ai l'ambition qu'on
aille vite je peux pas vous dire
aujourd'hui à quel point en ira vite
parce que il y a encore vous l'imaginez
des des arbitrages et cetera qui doivent
être pris mais l'engagement a été pris
et réaffirmé par la première ministre
elle-même lors de la conférence sociale
parce que encore une fois ce qui
s'étonnait parfois qu'il a un lien dans
le projet de loi plein emploi entre la
question de la garde d'enfant et de
l'emploi de facto c'est le cas de facto
c'est le cas et le premier frein
aujourd'hui à la réalisation du nombre
d'enfants au sein des couples c'est
l'angoisse le stress du mode de garde et
c'est un enjeu majeur d'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes de manière
évidente et d'ailleurs les pays dans
lequels la natalité la plus forte sont
aussi les pays dans lequel le taux
d'emploi des femmes est le plus fort
donc ça va en brèche aussi sans doute
parfois quelques intuitions des uns et
des autres donc si on veut une politique
forte de soutien à la natalité ben il
faut aussi une politique forte de
soutien à l'égalité entre les femmes et
les hommes et le congé parental pour moi
c'est quoi c'est de dire un qu'on peut
faire le constat qu'aujourd'hui au
regard du du taux d'activation du congé
parental moins de 1 % des paires seul 14
% des mares c'est clairement sa réforme
n'a pas fonctionné le nombre de
bénéficiaires a été divisé par deux
depuis la réforme qui a été faite ça
n'est pas un succès et donc à un moment
il faut pouvoir le réformer ou peut-être
même créer un droit nouveau à côté du
congé parental existant de manière à
garantir que plus de parents puissent
passer plus de temps auprès de leurs
jeunes enfants ce qui est bon pour les
parents qu'ils souhaite et ce qui est
bon évidemment pour nos enfants sur la
question de la pénurie des des
professionnels en vérité vous auriez pu
me poser la question sur l'ensemble des
secteurs malheureusement dont j'ai la
responsabilité l'ensemble des secteurs
du médico-social du soin du lien de
l'humain sont des secteurs aujourd'hui
qui connaissent des pénuries de
professionnel pour plein de raisons la
première c'est sans doute que pendant
des années on a trop peu considéré ces
métiers voir qu'on les a même pas
considéré comme des métiers à
partentière on n' pas considéré la
technicité de ces métiers mais en fait
une aide à domicile le simple fait de
porter une personne âgée en fait ça s'ap
prend c'est un métier nous ne sommes pas
nous former pour le faire le fait de
pouvoir accompagner soutenir aider à
l'épanouissement de nos enfants c'est
pas parce que nous sommes nous-mêmes
parents que nous pourrions le faire
c'est un métier donc il y a déjà
reconnaître que ce sont des métiers avec
des niveaux de formation qualification
et donc de reconnaissance salariale
évidemment qui doit pouvoir
l'accompagner et c'est clairement ce
qu'on fait c'est ce qu'on fait notamment
dans le secteur de la petite enfance
avec ce que je vous disais monsieur le
rapporteur 200 millions d'euros chaque
année à partir du 1er janvier 24 mais
que j'ai conditionné que j'ai conditionn
au fait que dans l'ensemble des
conventions collectives un que tous les
personnels soient sous conventions
Collectiv ce qui est pas le cas
aujourd'hui de que l'ensemble de ces
conventions collectives soi revalorisé à
la hausse à la fois sur la question des
bass salaires mais au-delà de la
question des des bas salaires sur la
formation La formation continue c'est
pas une journée pédagogique par an
évidemment qui peut suffire à satisfaire
ces ces besoins et cette même obligation
qu'on a être formé la mobilité
professionnelle la reprise aussi de
l'ancienneté professionnelle enfin
pardon je suis un peu long excusez-moi
sur la question du handicap et la
question notamment du du du diagnostic
précoce notre enjeu c'est déjà de rendre
lisible l'offre d'accompagnement ça
pourrait être le cas d'ailleurs dans
d'autres sujets l'accompagnement à
lapparentealité sur plein de sujets on a
là encore sans doute empilé beaucoup de
dispositifs mais l'objectif c'est
d'aller vers aller vers les familles
aller vers les familles qui sont souvent
les plus loin de nos administrations
pour garantir leur accompagnement et
donc garantir que 100 % des enfants
puissent bénéficier de cette détection
qui est précoce renforcer du coup les
moyens de nos centres médicaux-sociaux
et là on renforce les moyens
budgétairement dès ce PLFSS pour que ce
soit possible et garantir je dire là
aussi une prise en charge universelle
sans reste à charge parce que enfin je
pense que tous vous avez rencontré
peut-être vous êtes même directement
concerné des familles qui ont vécu
l'airrance de devoir aller une fois deux
fois trois fois quatre fois CIN fois
dans des rendez-vous qu'ils ont dû
prendre en charge eu même sur lesqueles
ils n'ont pas été accompagnés donc le
simple fait de se dire qu'on va avoir
enfin une prise en charge universelle
avec un reste à charge zéro pour les
familles et qui garantit une équité
territoriale qui fait qu'en fait il y a
pas de perte de chance en fonction du
département dans lequel vous êtes en
fonction de la famille dans laquelle
vous êtes né je crois que ça c'est
absolument déterminant et ça vient
évidemment au complément de de de ce qui
existe ça garanti aussi
euh la la quand je disis prise en charge
universelle typiquement que soit pas
uniquement par exemple pour les salariés
mais que ce soit aussi pour les libéraux
qui aujourd'hui n'avaient pas forcément
ce niveau d'accompagnement et de soutien
donc c'est à la fois encore une fois bon
pour les familles en terme
d'accompagnement de soutien pour éviter
ce parcours du combattant que beaucoup
trop d'entre eux continuent à nous
relater jour après jour évidemment bon
pour leurs enfants parce que plutôt ils
sont détectés mieux évidemment ils sont
pris en charge et accompagnés merci
Madame la Ministre alors j'ai SEP
demandes de parole donc je vous demande
d'être assez concis je commence par
Justine
guidez alors merci merci monsieur le
Président mais je crois que je vais être
un peu moins concise cette fois-ci si tu
le permets voilà parce que généralement
je suis très mais là voilà je vourais
juste revenir madame la ministre sur les
aides à domicile euh sur les territoires
ruraux c'est plutôt un public précaire
que nous avons mais surtout c'est que
nous avons un souci c'est-à-dire qu'ils
n't pas le moyen de se payer le permis
de conduire donc pas de voiture et donc
évidemment un recrutement beaucoup plus
difficile moi je pense qu'il faudrait
quand même qu'on arrive à une aide en
tous les cas quit à dire ben pendant 4 5
ans vous travaillerez vous dans ce
service là et vous pourrez pas bouger
voilà je sais pas me trouver une
solution là-dessus ensuite ma question
va porter sur l'article 38 du
PLFSS concernant justement la création
de repérage et d'accompagnement
précocece vous avez parlé dans ce
comment dire article 38 la rémunération
de tout ou partie des prestations liées
à ce parcours qui serait financé sous la
forme d'un forfait selon les modalités
qui seront définies par voie
réglementaire et la prise en charge des
frais sera assurée par l'assurance
maladie et les complémentaires de santé
dans le cadre des contrats responsables
alors ma question c'est je trouve que
cet article ne va pas assez loin pour
moi ce que l'on fait pour un enfant qui
a 4 ans aujourd'hui et qui aura 7 ans au
moment où ce dispositif entrera en
vigueur puisque c'est de 0 à 6 ans en
2025 que proposez-vous pour des
personnes concernées de 6 à 12 ans parce
qu'on sait très bien que les TND ça
s'arrête pas à 6 ans ou encore pour les
adultes comment envisagez-vous de
rattraper notre notre retard dans ce
domaine il est à noter que les
plateformes de coordination et
d'orientation PCO sont désormais à
destination des 06 ans et des 7 12 ans
tant tandis que ce nouveau service ne
concerne que les OS 6 ans comment
expliquez-vous cette incohérence je
crois que c'est parce que en manque de
je pense de professionnel et question
numéro 2 les frais médicaux pour les
moins de 6 ans sont remboursés de
manière forfaitaire une partie prise en
charge par l'assurance maladie et le
reste à charge par les mutuels santé que
se passe-t-il pour les enfants notamment
les parents surtout qui ne bénéficient
d'aucune mutuelle santé est-ce que
toutes les mutuelles accepteront aussi
de couvrir ses dépenses par ailleurs
parmi les textes réglementaires
nécessaires à l'application de cette
mesure figure un arrêté fixant le reste
à charge des assurés à ce service
d'action précoce donc alors j'ai cru
comprendre qu'il y aurait pas de reste à
charge donc je sais pas j'ai peut-être
pas bien compris euh alors je tiens
rappeler que ce service doit être un
service public s'adressant
particulièrement aux familles les plus
démunies et je réaffirme donc la
nécessité d'un reste à charge le plus
faible possible voire d'aucun rest à
charge comme c'est le cas pour les PCO
actuels enfin je voudrais vous remercier
en tous les cas pour les 24 départements
concernés pour le baluchonnage le fait
d'avoir repoussé un an je vous en
remercie mais il faut absolument que ça
soit pérenne voilà merci à vous merci
beaucoup Céline
Boulin merci président madame la
ministre vous avez dit
concernant le recrutement de 50000
soignants dans les éepades que la
trajectoire était tenue pour avoir comme
beaucoup ici écoutter attentivement le
présid ident de la République quand il
faisait campagne il évoquait 50000 sur
le quinquena parce que d'ailleurs je
vois mal comment il aurait pu s'engager
sur un quinquena suivant donc chacun
sait ici qu'il ne pourra pas être
président de la République donc en fait
on passe de 50000 places enfin postes de
2022 à
2027 à aujourd'hui 2030 donc je voudrais
savoir quel trajectoire vous entendez
tenir ça n'est évidemment pas du tout la
même chose quand on voit la situation de
nos épades euh évidemment on pourrait
imaginer que ce soit qu'on fasse qu'on
projette cet effort jusqu'à 2030 mais ça
nécessiterait une loi de programmation
avec par exemple un ratio qui serait
défini et qui serait tenu je crois que
beaucoup ici portent ça j'en suis mais
ça n'est je crois pas le cas deuxième
question sur le la compensation pour les
départements avec le tarif plancher
d'aide à domicile passer de 22 à 23 € et
qui va continuer de progresser ce qui
est une TR bonne chose la compensation
se fait sur le delta entre le tarif
pratiqué par les départements et celui
qui est désormais en vigueur partout ce
qui veut dire que ceux qui étaient plus
volontaristes et c'est le cas de d'une
diversité de département quel que soit
qui les dirige se retrouveve pénalisé
par rapport à ceux qui d'ailleurs
parfois pour des raisons financières ne
pouvaient pas assurer ce ce tarif est-ce
qu'il ne serait pas plus pertinent de
prendre en compte des critères de nombre
de population âgé des critères
démographiques des critères de moyens
des départements dont on sait qu'ils ne
sont pas les
même d'un département à l'autre et enfin
si vous m'y autorisez monsieur le
Président une question qui va déborder
sur le PLF mais qui est dans votre champ
de
compétence madame la ministre une
inquiétude monte de plus en plus parmi
les parents d'élèves d'élèves en
situation de handicap sur lespôle
d'appui à la
scolarisation dont ils craignent et on
peut partager leurs craintes qu'ils
viennent substituer les besoins ou les
moyens de l'institution au besoins des
d'accompagnement des enfants on avait
déjà eu le sujet avec la mise en place
des piales où il y a du bon et du
beaucoup moins bon avec des
mutualisations qui parfois ne
correspondent pas du tout au besoins
d'accompagnement des enfants et puis
derrière c'est la aujourd'hui les DPH
ont une certaine forme de neutralité
puisque ça n'est pas l'institution
éducation nationale ni aucun des
ministères qui décide de
l'accompagnement mais les MDPH est-ce
que si on passe à un système où c'est en
gros l'État qui va décider de
l'accompagnement des enfants on ne
risque pas que l'accompagnement soit
calibré au moyen de l'État et pas
d'abord au besoins des enfants merci
merci Jean-Marie van leberg faudra que
tu apprennes à dire bien bien bien mon
nom mon cher Philippe bon c'est vrai que
c'est plus facile de dire mouiller que
Van leurenberg
bon bon madame la ministre j'ai écouté
et apprécié d'ailleurs votre discours
très volontarisme et comme l'a précisé
mon ami collègue Olivier HUD nous
attendons les actes maintenant parce que
l'intention je ne doute pas d'ailleurs
de vos intentions d'avoir une politique
familiale complète
universelle comme vous l'avez dit mais
j'attends et je n'ai pas effectivement
le sentiment que partout dans le
PLFSS de cette année vous puissiez y
répondre vraiment avec ambition alors je
limiterai ma question uniquement à
l'aide à domicile et aux
épad je crois on a reçu ici le président
de la
CNSA on lui a dit on lui a fait part des
inquiétudes plus que des inquiétudes euh
c'est c'est c'est vraiment parfois de
l'alerte
maximale pour prendre un langage
météo les assauts en aide à domicile
sont en faillite dans mon département
mais c'est vrai aussi dans beaucoup
d'autres départements les épades sont
dans la même situation alors vous parlez
est-ce que c'est un déficit structurel
est-ce que c'est conjoncturel les deux
mon capitaine les deux vous avez
effectivement une augmentation des
rémunération et tant mieux et c'est
encore insuffisant si on veut
effectivement avoir l'ambition que vous
avez c'est-à-dire de rechercher des
personnels qualifiés compétents
formés je je ne doute pas moi de leur
intérêt hein parce que je connais
beaucoup beaucoup effectivement de ces
personnes elles sont généreuses et elles
ont envie de faire ce métier mais encore
faudrait-il qu'elles soit rémunéré
correctement donc pour ça il y a un un
effort encore à continuer et il y a
urgence c'est pas avec les 100 millions
qui sont concédés par la CNSA qu'on va y
répondre c'est du soupoudrage j'ai fait
remarquer Jean-René le cerf qu'il y
avait 1 mliard 3 d'excédent la CNSA 1
milliard 3 il faut les mobiliser tout de
suite tout de suite faut pas attendre la
fin 2024 c'est urgent donc c'est un cri
d'alarme que je vous lance madame la
ministre très bien
Agou alors dans la série il n'y a que
les ACT qui compte car les paroles vous
ne faites que les entendre alors j'ai
bien entendu votre détermination et
votre volontarisme comme l'ont dit mes
collègues je ne reviens pas sur les
questions concernant les éepad et ma
collègue Corine Ferret va pouvoir
reprendre ce point je vais me faire la
porte-parole de Madame Monique Lubin qui
est sénatrice des Landes et qui souhaite
vous interroger sur les questions la
question des résidences de répi partagé
lors de l'examen du projet de loi de
finance de 2003 le Sénat avait adopté à
l'unanimité ici donc un amendement qui
visait à permettre des solutions
temporaires de répis partagé entre les
aidants et leurs proches ces solutions
donc prennent la forme de résidence de
répi de vacances partagé et relève du
code de l'action sociale et des familles
en février dernier euh madame Lubin
avait interrogé votre prédécesseur il
s'agissait de savoir si le gouvernement
envisageait de mettre à disposition les
crédits nécessaires au financement des
places puisque les engagements étaient
pris et là la réponse du gouvernement
est plus ambigu alors aujourd'hui la
nouvelle stratégie a dans
2023-2027 dévoiler le 6 octobre dernier
fait mention du répis et des vacances
partagées mais ni chiffrage ni
calendrier n'ont été évoqué à cette
occasion et je vous entends aujourd'hui
à à nouveau parler de 40000 solutions de
repos de répis pardon pour les aidants
donc dans les
Landes donc département de Madame Lubin
le projet est prêt le site est identifié
les études préalables et le programme
immobilier sont en cours de finalisation
le dossier financier est prêt et est
prêt à être déposé aux autorités sous
réserve évidemment des financements
prévu prévus pour cela alors pouvez-vous
nous dire aujourd'hui quel est
le chiffrage et le calendrier prévu pour
permettre le dépôt de ces dossiers qui
concerne dans mon exemple les lande mais
je sais qu'il y a aussi des des projets
prêt en Bretagne en Normandie et en
Occitanie il nous manque juste l'adresse
de l'établissement d' voilà très bien
Madame le ministre je vous laisse
répondre à cette première série de
questions merci Monsieur le le président
là encore je vais essayer de répondre
par bloc d'abord sur la question des
aides à domicile le conseil est très
nette c'est la profession la plus
féminisée de France 99 % de femmes euh
mais l'une des plus pauvres aussi
puisqu'on a un taux de pauvreté de 19 %
euh pour celles qui exercent cette
mission auprès chaque jour d'un million
de personnes euh personnes en perte
d'autonomie ou personnes handicapé il y
a deux réponses qu'on peut apporter euh
si l'assemblée en décide puis ensuite
vous qui sont dans la proposition loi
bien vieillir puisqu'il y a la question
la création d'un fond mobilité puisqu'on
augmenterait vous le savez euh le le la
question du kilométrage aujourd'hui
c'est 0,38 centimes on souhaite le
passer à 0,55 donc ça veut dire que on
soutiendrait quand même clairement mieux
moi je pense qu'on peut aller plus loin
sur la question des flottes de véhicules
parce que aujourd'hui en vérité on aide
on accompagne avec des indemnités
kilométrique je pense qu'on peut faire
mieux notamment en accompagnant en
aidant est-ce que c'est du leasing
est-ce que c'est de l'achat on a vous le
savez la question du leasing sur les
voitures électriques je pense que c'est
aussi un enjeu d'ailleurs écologique
elles ont souvent des voitures qui sont
pas récentes qui leur coûte très cher
aussi en terme d'entretien je pense que
là encore la CNSA pourrait plus et mieux
contribuer en lien avec les départements
pour expérimenter des choses un peu
nouvelles au-delà des indemnités
kilométriques sur des flottes de
véhicules qui rendraient les personnes
plus autonomes euh et qui clairement
baisseraiit leur reste à charge en tout
cas il faut sortir de cette situation
invraisemblable où quelque part elle
payent pour avoir le droit de travailler
euh en moyenne c'est 2000 € par an euh
qu'elle payent je dis elle au regarde du
nombre qu'elles sont pratiqué euh sur
sur la question de l'essence donc je
pense que là-dessus c'est un enjeu un
enjeu majeur qu'on doit évidemment
réussir à à résoudre sur la question du
tarif planché madame la sénatrice euh
j'essayie d'y répondre tout à l'heure
moi je pense qu'en effet on n'a pas
choisi la bonne option à l'époque voilà
je peux pas le dire plus clairement euh
donc je le dis ici comme ça ce sera sans
doute entendu et dit à l'extérieur mais
on est venu compenser des départements
qui n'avaient pas fait l'effort sur la
question des aides à domicile après il
faut comprendre est-ce qu'ils l'ont pas
fait parce que c'était trop compliqué
est-ce qu'ils l'ont pas fait parce que
budgetirement ils avaient pas les moyens
il a quelques départements où je pense
qu'ils en avaent les moyens et qu'ils
n'ont pas fait ce virage là et du coup
moi je me retrouve avec des départements
notamment des départements ruraux qui me
disent bah nous on avait fait cet effort
on était déjà à 22 € et du coup on n
rien touché donc quand je parle de vraie
réforme des fronts concours c'est une
vraie refonte réforme des fonds de
concours et l'assumer de tout remettre à
plat en discussion avec avec les
départements mais je crois encore une
fois qu'il faut se donner les moyens de
l'ambition qui doit être la nôtre sur
l'adaptation de notre société au
vieillissement et sur le soutien
évidemment aux professionnels sur la
question d'une loi de programmation
c'est une question qui est là aussi
posée puisque c'est un amendement qui a
été adopté à l'unanimité à l'Assemblée
nationale dans le cadre de la
proposition de loi j'ai dit que de toute
façon il convient que le gouvernement
respecte les engagements qui ont été
demandés par le Parlement not en plus
quand ils sont adoptés à l'unanimité
donc je pense que ça peut nous permettre
d'esquisser est-ce que c'est une loi de
programmation est-ce que c'est une
d'orientation sans doute aussi de mettre
plus de de cohérence et de lisibilité
par rapport à ce que nous faisons sur
les moyens justement qui sont dévolue
aux enjeux de de l'autonomie dans notre
dans notre pays sur la question vous
l'avez posé monsieur le sénateur il y a
pas d'excédent en fait il y a pas
d'excédent parce que notre enjeu c'est
de garantir quand même une trajectoire
jusqu'en 2027 et si je consomme 100 %
aujourd'hui des 2,6 milliards ça veut
dire que je ne peux pas devant vous vous
dire que la trajectoire qui est la nôtre
sur les 50000 nouvelles solutions sur la
question des 50000 soignants sera tenu
parce que c'est une trajectoire
justement notamment sur les 50000
nouvelles solutions jusqu'en 2027 moi ce
que j'ai dit par contre au département
c'est que j'étais prête que le
gouvernement était prêt dès 2024 à avoir
un effort renforcé et avoir une
enveloppe budgétaire supplémentaire au
bénéfice des départements mais consommer
tout aujourd'hui c'est prendre le risque
très clairement que nous n'ayons pas les
moyens ensuite de garantir les ambitions
qui sont les nôtres si tentz qu'encore
une fois il faille tout consommer
maintenant alors qu'encore une fois les
charges sont différentes les moyens
doivent être répartis sur les
territoires et que vous ne pourrez pas
créer 50000 solutions en une année vous
ne pourrez pas avoir 50000 soignant en
une année et cetera donc je pense qu'il
faut se poser une question peut-être de
plus long terme sur le financement de la
branche autonomie à long terme au-delà
encore une fois des 015 points de CSG je
pense que ça c'est une question
évidemment à l'Assemblée au Sénat qui
est clairement devant nous
collectivement sur quels sont les moyens
concrètement qui seront dévolués à la
branche autonomie est-ce qu'il faut
aller au-delà de ce qui a été déjà
défini par les 015 points de CSG ça
c'est une vraie question
mais bah déjà il a il y a une
proposition de loi qui est sur la table
qui répond à un certain nombre des des
enjeux et après est-ce qu'il doit y
avoir un projet de loi ça c'est un sujet
dont on débattra évidemment au sein du
gouvernement et je l'ai dit notamment
est-ce qu'il faut une loi de cadrage
d'orientation de programmation j'y suis
ouverte donc je peux pas dire autre
chose devant
vous non mais monsieur le sénateur
j'entends évidemment et cette
préoccupation je vous assure qu'elle est
la mienne au quotidien parce qu'il y a
pas un jour où j'ai pas un maire un
président de département un directeur
d'établissement qui ne m'interpelle pas
une fédération sur ici un épal ici un
service d'aide à domicile ici des
personnes directement concernées qui ne
m'interpellent pas en disant qu'est-ce
qui va se passer pour mon père ma ma
grand-mère et cetera donc j'ai
pleinement conscience de ce que vous
dites pleinement mais ça suppose
qu'encore une fois on arrive à faire
plusieurs choses en parallèle qu'on
arrive à prendre le virage domiciliaire
et c'est pas juste des mots on a mis 1
milliard d'euros sur la table depuis
2017 sur le domicile 1 milliard d'euros
d'engagement de l'État c'est très
conséquent et qu'on le fasse mieux en
lien évidemment avec les départements
pour garantir la rémunération de celles
qui concrètement s'engage sur le terrain
au-delà de l'adaptation du domicile
c'est la question encore une fois de
quel virage on fait prendre en terme de
modèle économique à nos épades on voit
bien aujourd'hui et vous avez je pense
des exemples très disparates dans chacun
de vos départements des épades qui ont
fait le choix d'être de plus en plus
médicalisé qui ont créé des unités
protégées pour les maladies
neurodégénératives je pense à Alzheimer
en particulier ceux qui aujourd'hui sont
plus adapté aux besoins des populations
directement concerné donc ça veut dire
qu'il faut se poser la question de leur
modèle économique et de leur capacités
et de la manière avec laquelle on peut
les transformer et ce que j'évoquais
aussi tout ce qui se passe en
intermédiaire il y a des personnes
person qui ne peuvent pas rester à
domicile mais qui en fait n'ont pas la
place leur place en éepad parce que ça
n'est pas un environnement qui serait
adapté pour elle demain donc
concrètement il se passe quoi sur cet
habitat intermédiaire cet habitat
inclusif c'est résidence autonomie c'est
résidence seigor et pour moi tout cela
doit se faire évidemment en lien avec
les engagements financiers et de l'État
et des départements d'où encore une fois
la réforme des fonds de concours qui
doit permettre d'avoir enfin des
critères pertinents objectifs
adressable aux différents départements
et je ne pense pas que ce soit ce qui a
été fait ces 10 15 dernières années
parce qu'à la fin encore une fois on a
empilé on n' pas donné de lisibilité et
on a peut-être aussi découragé des
départements qui avaient envie d'agir et
qui se disaient que finalement ils
avaient peu d'incitation et et d'intérêt
à agir sur la question enfin du droit au
répis oui c'est un enjeu absolument
déterminant encore une fois on voit que
l'état de santé des aidents des aidents
familiaux se dégradent parce qu'ils
oublient souvent leur propre santé parce
qu'ils prennent soin de la personne
qu'ils aiment mais résultat encore une
fois elle se dégrade parfois certains
disparaissent même avant la personne
qu'il qu'es accompagnent donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle on annonce avec
Fadil la catabi la création de 6000
places de répis supplémentair en plus de
l'aide journalière aux édents en plus du
congé prochdents en disant que les deux
maintenant peuvent se cumuler puisqu'on
peut être aidant pour plusieurs
personnes en même temps on peut être
aidant pour plusieurs personnes au cours
de sa vie donc on doit pouvoir cumuler
c'est ce qu'on ouvre dans ce pfss le
congé prochédans notamment et on a un
certain nombre de de solutions sur la
question de l'accueil temporaire moi je
pense que là-dessus c'est sans doute ce
que vous évoquez la Catrice c'est que on
a peut-être eu des modèles qui étaient
un petit peu trop rigides sur ce qu'on
considère être des plateformes de répi
on doit pouvoir faire du répi la nuit
par exemple et il y a parfois un certain
de de solutions qui doivent pouvoir
exister juste la nuit pour un certain
nombre de personnes qui doivent pouvoir
être accompagné on doit pouvoir faire du
répi partagé parce qu'encore une fois on
n' pas forcément envie de laisser seul
son parent ou son enfant on a peut-être
juste besoin d'avoir du temps pour soi
du temps pour lui mais au même endroit
c'est le répi partagé je comprends qu'il
y a un certain nombre d'amendements qui
ont été ou qui vont être déposés en ce
sens moi je souhaite qu'on puisse
avancer sur le sujet donc on aura
évidemment le débat avec vous ici au
Sénat mais s'il y a des éléments
d'amélioration sur le droit au répis
partagé au nom du gouvernement moi j'y
serai favorable et si vous avez des
projets très concrets à me faire
remonter n'hésitez pas par
l'intermédiaèire du président de la
Commission à me les faire passer si on
peut accélérer des solutions qui sont
bonnes pour les Français je serai
évidemment la première favorable à les
porter j'ai toutes les adresses allez
cor alors il nous reste 18 minutes
question réponse Corine Corine FERR
merci monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre j'entends bien vos propos mais
je reviendrai à mon tour sur la
situation dramatique on va dire des
établissements qui accueillent des
personnes âgé notamment alors je veux
revenir aussi puisqu'on parle bien là du
PLFSS et de la branche autonomie il est
annoncé en excédent certes mais
n'oublions pas que les besoins pour
prendre soin des personnes âgées
dépendantes notamment s'élève à 9
milliards d'euros annuels donc le
l'excédent est insuffisant que aucune
nouvelle ressource n soit prévue à part
effectivement c'est pas négligeable
cette fraction de recette venant de la
CSG donc on peut y mettre les moyens et
on doit y mettre les moyens vous avez
dit je reprends vos mots madame la
ministre je veux grandir il faut grandir
la branche autonomie mais il faut y
mettre les moyens il ne suffit pas de
dire on faire des annonces où on va dire
avoir des intentions il faut y mettre
des moyens je je le répète euh parce que
vous avez dit également être prête à
faire un effort j'y reviendrai en
direction des départements en direction
des établissements donc en très grande
difficulté mais avec quel moyen vous
avez évoqué le fait que ces 10 dernières
années il n'y a pas eu suffisamment de
moyen de porter mais je me permets sans
être désagréable mais simplement factuel
de dire que depuis 2017 et bien la
majorité présidentielle dont vous êtes
membre et aujourd'hui vous êtes ministre
était en responsabilité que ces moyens
auraient pu être portés année après
année parce que ce que nous disent les
élus et vous nous avez bien indiquer je
m'en réjouis que vous irez prochainement
dans les Côtes d'Armor puisque
effectivement un collectif d'élus ont
alerté sur la situation gravissime et
dramatique de leurs établissements mais
j'ai envie de vous inviter très
officiellement à venir aussi dans
Calvados parce que là aussi ils ont
alerté sur la situation gravissime est
très difficile des établissements alors
peut-être que votre agenda dans les
jours à venir sera occupé par un tour de
France parce que dans chacun des
département vous serez amené à
rencontrer des directeurs d'pad des élus
qui vous qui vous signifieront cette
grande inquiétude parce que comme l'a
dit notre collègue tout à l'heure s'il
n'y a plus les épades et bien ce sont
les personnes âgées qui ne pourront plus
être accueilllies pris en charge vous
avez dit dans dans vos propos que nous
sommes face tous collectivement un
véritable défi un véritable choc
démographique par rapport donc au
vieillissement de la population et je
souhaite que tous un jour nous devenions
vieux et vieille et que nous puissions
aussi compter sur cette prise en charge
alors ma question elle est très simple à
quand à quand une grande loi sur
l'autonomie sur la prise en charge donc
des de du grand âge depuis
2018 il y a eu cette annonce du
président de la République nous
connaissons la situation les rapports je
veux citer le rapport Libau mais aussi
le rapport alcomerie ont bien indiqué ce
qu'il en était ce que vous nous dites
que à court terme on peut dire
maintenant bien évidemment la population
vieillissante pardon va être de plus en
plus importante nous le savons il faut
prendre des mesur qui répondent à ce
défi qui répondent à ce défi euh euh
sociétal on va dire hein euh et là
aujourd'hui y compris dans ce PLFSS euh
ces moyens sont insuffisants vous avez
parlé des métier liés au au grand âge
euh là aussi ce n'est pas nouveau vous
le savez comme nous depuis nombreuses
années et je veux juste terminer sur
l'article 37 et sur la réforme euh en
particulier de la fusion soins
dépendance euh ce qui est proposé
aujourd'hui dans le texte de ce que j'ai
compris mais peut-être ai-je mal compris
euh et bien ce n'est pas une phase
expérimentale c'est les départements qui
le souhaitent pourrait ceux qui ne le
souhaitent pas ne le feront pas donc
vous avez dit à tout à fait ouverte au
principe d'expérimentation je vous
invite si je peux me permettre peut-être
ne suis-je plus dans mon rôle à proposer
un amendement du Gouvernement quand on
débattra du PLFSS parce qu'aujourd'hui
ce n'est pas ce que le texte propose
merci beaucoup Corine
corinebert merci monsieur le Président
merci Madame la Ministre euh une
remarque et deux questions très courtes
la remarque madame la ministre c'est que
j'ai bien entendu vos propos concernant
votre volonté de pas pénaliser les
conseils
départementaux
je vous en prie madame la ministre les
conseils départementaux qui se sont déjà
engagés dans l'élaboration d'un tarif
planché et et également qui sont allés
plus loin en en aidant les services
d'aide à domicile à s'équiper ou en tout
cas à louer des flottes de véhicules il
y en a donc voilà vous êtes engagé ce
qu'il ne soit pas pénalisé et bien sûr
comme nous sommes tous des élus des
territoires nous nous y vaillerons euh
deux questions très courtes nous sommes
puisque nous sommes sur un un plan de un
projet de loi de financement quel est le
le montant euh des mesures nouvelles si
on on met de côté les faits
bénéficiaires euh si je compare le
tableau d'équilibre rectifié
2023 pour la branche autonomie et la
branche famille et le tableau
d'équilibre euh 2024 pour ces deux mêmes
branche à chaque fois on a 2 milliards
d'euros en dépenses inscrit d'accord 2
milliards de plus en branche famille
c'est bon donc euh quel est le montant
de ces dans ces 4 milliards si je les
cumule quel est le montant des mesures
nouvelles si l' met côté les fait
bénéficiaires si vous êtes pas en mesure
de me répondre j'aurai la réponse plus
tard c'est pas grave et euh quel est et
est-ce que est-ce que euh vous êtes sur
la même ligne que votre
prédécesseur qui disait que la politique
autonomie étant une une compétence des
conseils départementaux quand le
gouvernement mettra 1 € je vous
demanderez au Conseil départementaux de
mettre 1 € je vous remerci beaucoup Anne
Sophie
Romani merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre al je vais reprendre
les propos de ma de ma collègue tout à
l'heure concernant le risque dépendance
et et la perte d'autonomie et plus
particulièrement le reste à charge pour
les familles puisqueaujourd'hui il est
estimé à 500 € médian par personnes
dépendantes ce qui est un reste à charge
énorme pour les familles sachant que on
sait très bien que l'État pourra pas
prendre en charge faut faut faut pas se
se raconter
d'histoire pas assez de de prévention en
tout cas aujourd'hui puisque nous
constatons que peu de Français ont une
couverture dépendance j'ai rencontré la
Mutualité Française tout à l'heure qui
me
proposit un enfin me demandait si vous
pouviez envisager une cotisation pour le
risque dépendance une sorte de
solidarité collective puisque à un
moment nous n'arriverons pas enfin on
est loin mais ça se rapproche et que à
un moment il faudra quand même prendre
des mesures efficaces et on peut pas
compter sur l'état et sur les fonds
d'État pour solutionner le problème à
terme merci marido
aschlemman merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre tout d'abord je
voudrais prendre acte de du discours
volontariste que vous avez eu concernant
le le libre choix que vous voulez donner
aux familles en ce qui concerne la prise
en charge des des enfants des jeunes
enfants et puis aussi la volonté de
diversifier les différents modes de
garde donc nous sommes très attentifs et
vous avez observé qu'il y avait beaucoup
d'attentes par rapport à cette question
euh mon propos portera plus
particulièrement sur la situation des
épades public
euh les récents événements ont montré
qu'il y avait eu beaucoup d'mis autour
de d'un certain nombre d'éran et de de
difficultés là il se trouve qu'un
certain nombre d'épat de public et nous
sommes nombreux à être saisis au niveau
de nos départements euh rencontre des
difficultés financières alors vous avez
tout à l'heure distingué entre le
conjoncturel et le structurel et là en
l'occurrence il semblerait que les
mesures salariales qui ont été décidées
euh les euh l'impact de l'inflation sur
les coûts et et les tarifs et l'énergie
se traduit par des grosses difficultés
par un certain nombre d'pades public
donc la question c'est de savoir si le
calibrage de long d'â à ce stade euh
nous permet de d'anticiper une prise en
compte à un niveau efficient de ces
difficultés qui sont rencontrées par les
épates
publics merci et enfin pour terminer
Marie pericher merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre je vais
faire court parce que je vais revenir
sur les alertes qui ont été évoquées par
mes collègues à plusieurs reprises
concernant la situation des associations
d'aide à domicile euh parce que c'est un
vrai sujet c'est pas un sujet pour dans
dans un an ou dans quelques mois dans le
département du Cher nous avons deux
associations en redressement aujourd'hui
le Conseil départemental vous a écrit
ainsi qu'à qu'à d'autres qu'à d'autres
ministres cignés par les parlementaires
parce que nous constatons tous et ça a
été rappelé que le fond d'urgence n'est
pas suffisant et je voulais moi savoir
qu'est-ce que vous allez mettre en place
aujourd'hui pour soutenir les conseils
despart ementaux et notamment le le
soutien au aux aides à domicile aux
associations d'aide à domicile qui cette
problématique est lié aussi à la
difficulté d'accès aux soins merci merci
madame la ministre je vous laisse
répondre
oui merci Monsieur le le
président sur la question donc toujours
de de la branche autonomie je retrouvais
les les chiffres en 2022 on était à 35
milliards d'euros pour la branche
autonomie en 202 7 on atteindra 45
milliards d'euros c'estd 30 %
d'augmentation et d'engagement de l'État
supplémentaire pour la branche autonomie
donc les moyens sont clairement
consacrés et sont clairement en
augmentation avec en corollaire un
engagement qu'on a pris qu' a pas de
hausse d'impôt nouvell sur les Français
je crois qu'on parle justement de reste
à charge de reste à vivre on imagine mal
demander en tout cas N du gouvernement
on imagine mal demander un effort
supplémentaire via via l'impôt au
français donc ça ça veut dire qu'il y a
une montée en puissance qui est quand
même très nette de la branche autonomie
et qui est totalement légitime et
nécessaire encore une fois au regard du
du défi démographique qui est devant
nous une forme peut-être de dénis encore
individuel et collectif sur ce que ça va
générer dans la société peut-être
assumer de se dire qu'au départ tout ça
part d'une bonne nouvelle on a presque
l'impression qu'on l'a oublié mais que
l'idée que l'espérance de vie progresse
et que l'espérance de vie en bonne santé
progresse devrait d'abord nous réjouir
avant de nous désespérer de nous
inquiéter donc je tiens quand même à le
redire ici c'est une bonne nouvelle qui
suppose des adaptations qui suppose des
financements qui suppose des menures
structurelles qui doivent évidemment
être prise mesures structurelles donc
c'est ce que j'essayé de dire évidemment
en lien avec les départements en
coportage en terme de responsabilité de
compétences et d'engagement financier eu
je suis pas là à dire c'est 1 € pour 1 €
parce que je pense que la question elle
est un petit peu différente encore une
fois en fonction de l'engagement des
départements en fonction de leur
situation budgétaire en fonction du type
d'établissement aussi qu'ils ont on a je
disais que je me rendais en Bretagne il
y a eu un choix assez structurant en
Bretagne depuis de longues années des
pâes publques des pattes qui sont
portées par des CCS on a d'autres
départements où on a des pâes privées
qui sont largement majoritaires le sujet
il est pas pour moi de de faire le tri
entre les modèles économiques c'est pas
mon propos mais ça veut dire
qu'évidemment ça n'est pas la même
situation pour les départements en
fonction de la cartographie des
établissement dont ils héritent aussi
parce que c'est une histoire depuis 20
ans 30 ans et parfois parfois plus qui
suppose à mon avis qui est quand même
au-delà d'une politique évidemment qui
doit être équitable territorialement
qu'on puisse avoir de la différenciation
pour accompagner plus et mieux certains
des départements évitant par contre
l'écueil que vous avez à nouveau redit
tout à l'heure qui a été fait par
exemple sur la question du tarif planché
ça pour le coup je ne veux pas
reproduire cet écueil là parce que je
pense qu'il est très désincitatif encore
une fois pour ceux qui veulent et qui
souhaitent s'engager la question en
effet des épades public elle est
malheureusement très généralisée hein je
ne peux pas vous dire que je connaisse
beaucoup d'établissements qui soient
aujourd'hui en excédent j'aimerais mais
c'est pas totalement les situations qui
qui nous remontent et encore une fois
les les commissions qu'on a installé au
niveau départemental leur objectif n'est
pas juste de pouvoir distribuer j'allais
dire le le fond d'urgence leur objectif
est évidemment de faire ça pour
accompagner les établissements qui en
ont le plus besoin les services d'aide à
domicile qui en ont le plus besoin et
d'aller le plus vite possible évidemment
mais c'est enfin d'arriver à
cartographier à accompagner à
réorganiser à restructurer parce qu'on
voit bien encore une fois qu'il y a
certains établissement moi je pour être
clair je ne veux pas me retrouver dans
la situation et que les présidents de
département se retrouvent dans la
situation où dans 6 mois on aura les
mêmes difficultés dans les mêmes
établissements et puis dans un an et
puis dans 18 mois et ainsi de suite déjà
parce qu'encore une fois en terme de
finances publique et de finan des
départements ça ne serait pas tenable
mais parce que ça n'est pas une bonne
manière de gérer et d'organiser la
réponse qu'on doit pouvoir apporter
parce qu'on peut pas avoir cette
angoisse qui pèse sur le directeur
d'établissement qui donc pèse aussi sur
sa capacité à recruter qui pèse sur les
familles de se dire mais en fait cette
situation elle va se répéter dans 6 mois
dans un an et dans 18 mois donc ça
suppose au-delà encore une fois des des
annonces très conjoncturelles et des
soutiens financiers supplémentaires
qu'on doit apporter y compris service
d'aide à domicile qui sont embarqués sur
la question du fond d'urgence qu'on ait
des enjeux plus structurels avec des
décisions à prendre encore une fois qui
peuvent par fois être de repositionner
un épal je le disais sur de l'habitat
intermédiaire par exemple et évidemment
j'entends la question du reste à charge
pour les familles euh parce que c'est
une des principales préoccupations il y
a la reste à charge pour les familles il
y a aussi la question du reste à vivre
aujourd'hui pour les résidents qui est à
100 € qui a pas été revalorisé depuis
très longtemps moi je pense qu'il y a
aussi sans doute un effort ou des
modification qui mériterait d'être faite
parce que 100 € d'il y a 15 ans ne sont
pas 100 € évidemment aujourd'hui euh et
donc je pense que au regard de
l'inflation et cetera euh j'imagine que
ca aura des réflexions sur le sujet ça
mérite sans doute qu'il y ait des
ajustements encore une fois il y a les
deux sujets pour moi qui sont pas exact
qui recouvrent pas exactement les mêmes
réalités hein de reste à charge pour les
familles solidarité intergénérationnelle
de comment ça pèse sur la vie des
familles mais aussi de rester à vivre
pour pour les résidents eux-mêmes et je
le disais il y a un enjeu au-delà encore
une fois de la trajectoire
2023-2027 qui est à terme sur le
financement de la branche autonomie euh
on disait en apparé avec le président ça
mériterait une audition à soi seul ce ce
sujet sans doute et je suis évidemment à
votre disposition parce que des facto je
pense qu'il faudra se poser la question
du financement à long terme parce que la
question du vieillissement ne va pas
aller en décroissant voilà je désolé de
de dire d'enfoncer une porte ouverte
mais donc il faut quand même prendre
conscience que ces enjeux structurels de
financement et de coportage avec les
départements et la réforme qu'on doit
engager des fonds de concours c'est pas
une réforme pour les deux trois
prochaines années ça doit être la
réforme pour les 10 15 prochaines années
en terme d'organisation non pas des
compétences mais d'organisation du du
coportage et du cofinancement évidemment
avec avec les départements et j'embarque
systématiquement non pas uniquement la
question je pense que vous l'avez noté
non pas uniquement des epads non pas
uniquement du domicile mais vraiment de
l'ensemble du parcours et de
l'accompagnement que l'on doit à nos
familles puisqueencore une fois on parle
de de nos parents et de nos
grands-parents merci à vous pour vos
questions si Madame la Ministre on est
juste en temps donc
17h question oui dises-moi
dis-mi
oui alors excusez-moi si je vous ai pas
répondu sur la question des des des 06
ans la question du forfait en fait le
forfait c'est une prescription qui va
être faite d'un nombre de séances et
donc ces séances seront prises en charge
à 100 %. donc il y a pas d'ambiguité
là-dessus mais il faut qu'il y ait une
base à moment médical aussi de savoir
quel est le niveau qui doit être accordé
d'accompagnement sur les 7 12 ans là
aussi on a on a a des réponses on a des
plateformes de coordination et
d'orientation qui viennent juste en
suivi donc en fait on crée quelque chose
de nouveau sur les 06 ans pour avoir une
complétude en fait de l'offre de
l'accompagnement de soutien aux familles
et de de détection précoce et on a en
plus en soutien évidemment des 7 12 ans
en particulier avec les plateformes de
coordination et et d'orientation et si
vous avez d'autres questions n'hésitez
pas pardon voilà peut-être que je je ce
que je propose je envoyer envoie un mail
voilà je viendrai voilà voilà très bien
Madame les ministre merci pour cette
cette audition et puis euh j'ai on a 2
minutes de pause avant la dernière
audition à 17h avec le ministre
casazenav